as leader of the government guzik
Picanto had overseen one of the most
challenging coalition's in recent times
battling one political crisis after
another contained at being a stabilizing
force between two vastly different
political parties the far-right league
and the anti-establishment 5 star
movement it proved to be an impossible
task and Cantus said he would be
offering his resignation but there was
no question over who he thought was
responsible let me say that Interior
Minister salvini has shown that he is
following his own interests and those of
his party in a blistering attack against
salvini quanti accused him of unleashing
further turmoil and in doing so
endangering italy's already stagnant
economy but the League party leader was
unrepentant corner I would do again
everything I did everything with the
great strength of being a free man
therefore it means I'm not afraid of the
judgement of the Italians overshadowing
this impasse has been Matteo Salva knees
own political agenda vocally
anti-migrant he's also waged war on the
NGOs that have attempted to rescue
asylum seekers crossing the
Mediterranean and it's a tactic that has
had success support for his views have
increased across the country turning his
party into a force that cannot be
ignored in the middle of this political
drama this Spanish rescue vessel
hovering off the coast of lumpy Rosa
with dozens of vulnerable people on
board for more than two weeks they had
not been given permission to disembark
the open arms vessels repeatedly
requested permission to dock
despite continued rejection someone
board became so frantic they risked
their own lives by jumping into the sea
attempting to swim to land they were
rescued by nearby Italian Coast Guard
vessels on Tuesday a local prosecutor
visited the vessel and issued an
emergency measure allowing it to dock in
lumpy loser but this is one incident
among many others despite tough new laws
preventing such landings they still
arrive desperate for safety in Europe no
matter the cost of reaching there
Sonia guy a go al-jazeera Rome